hi everyone everyone in the room thank
you for enjoying this beautiful day with
me inside so today I'm going to be
talking about BQ plot and interactive
visualization library that we developed
while I was at Bloomberg and still the
most of the contributors are from
Bloomberg if you want to follow this
talk all mine the notebooks I'm going to
be showing are on github and I'm just on
that link and you can follow it there
okay so what is BQ plot so BQ plot is an
interactive plotting library for the
jupiter notebook it's a battery licensed
it's completely open sourced under
Bloomberg so you can anyone can use it
you can deploy it in your commercial
product the most frequent question I get
when I say oh yeah have you tried our BQ
plot is a really another another library
I mean there's like 10 api's to remember
already and that's a fair point
hopefully someone will unify them soon
but why should you learn BQ plot in the
meanwhile well so we we build BQ plot to
leverage the Jupiter notebook to
leverage the fact that it's in a browser
to leverage how the interactivity can be
bi-directional to leverage the widgets
framework that that comes with the
native Jupiter so doing very complicated
interactive dashboards is extremely
simple and BQ plot and hopefully I'm
going to convince you about that in the
stock so yeah so the the cool thing
which will see what it means that in is
that be Cuba in BQ plot every element of
a chart is an interactive widget that
means once you generate a chart you can
change it as you want change any aspect
of it and that's going to change the
original rendering we come with two
api's which one is kind of a matplotlib
inspired api and the other one is an
object model and finally it's built on
that native jupiter widgets ecosystem
and so it plays well with anything else
that
built on that so if you want to do 3d
visualization that includes by 3GS if
you want to do leaflet visualizations I
buy leaflet if you want to do really
complicated 3d visualization I think
Martin brothels wrote I by volume and
just so this is the BQ platin
out of that I think Jason is sitting
right there most of the people are at
Bloomberg in the quantitative research
group except Jason and Sylvan is at Guan
stack and I'm at Amazon and we're always
looking for contributors like any
project so if you like this stuff feel
free to go to the repo and submit a PR
we're happy to review it and we're
usually quite active on the git er as
well okay so eg black net let me see how
that looks
and build zoom in a little bit okay so
let's let's start let's start the live
demo which is always your ski so forgive
me there any bugs yes so say we have a
set of data say X data and Y data and we
wanted to plot that out BQ blot works
exactly it has an API that that's
inspired by math libs so plotting that
should be pretty simple you just do a
little scatter plot and you have it
voila but the cool thing about BQ plot
is that what's being rendered is
actually a fully interactive web element
so you can zoom man you can do whatever
you would like you can save the image
you can reset the zoom it's it's it's
really this is a web element in the
browser that you can live at it the cool
thing about that is once you define this
object scatter you can change any aspect
of it after the fact so if you run if
you say let me change the Y values of
the scatter that's going to change it
right within the notebook itself it's
going to change the original plot you
keep a lot is based on d3.js the cool
thing about that is you can leverage all
the different things in d3 including
animations and selections so if you set
an animation time of say 500 and
then you change the block so each time
you change the block you're going to see
that the blood is going to do animate as
pretty much any duty visualization would
yes so you can change the colors and
it's going to make it red you can change
the marker it's going to make it
diamonds if you want the thing that
makes B people are really powerful the
reason that you can build fully
interactive applications from it is that
if you define say you define a function
foo in Python you can actually say to
the magic of trade list that for my
scatter plot I want to observe the
function foo whenever the Y values are
changed okay what does that mean that
means that say we set the enable move
property to be true that means that
every time we take a point and we move
it foo is going to be called so it's
it's truly bi-directional and that in
the sense that yes so if you change the
function it's going to mean there is
going to give you say let's print what
it sends to you so in that case you can
just what is it going to send to you is
oops I'm a something I'll never do a
live demo that is really the greatest
risk you can take it's going to send to
you the it's going to send to you the
object that it's going to tell you which
indices were changed and what the values
of the data points that were changed
were so that's not the only API that BQ
plot comes with it comes with an object
model - which really respects the kind
of grammar of graphics paradigm which
means that when you construct a chart
you construct it from all the different
elements like a scale and access a
marker and finally you compose all of
that into a figure so in mpq bottoms
would be set of objects that are that
are called scales that many different
types in this case we pick a linear
scale
we import the object called scatter we
pass the the scales to the scatter so
that it knows what's going on we can
create do axes and x-axis and a y-axis
and a figure which contains the marks
which are the scatter a title and axis
which we defined above and once we show
that that's exactly the same figure so
there's two ways to compose the same
plot the good thing about this is that
well you can do this in the other API as
well but you can say say you have a set
of color data say this was a stock price
and you'd bought it or sold it at a
certain time you can define color data
which would be a numpy array in this
case just in zeros and ones for when you
bought and sold it scales don't only
apply to the x and y axis they can also
apply to colors so you can set the
scales to be you can just add a color
scale in this case and set the color to
be the color data that's going to that's
going to color the entire plot based on
the data that you passed it so you can
yeah basically you can color a core you
can use the color as an extra dimension
to represent one more aspect of your
data if you use a if you use the bars so
yeah so if you want to compose many
different charts on a single on a single
figure you can all you have to do is
make sure that they share the same
scales and and then just add them to the
figure and once you do that you you have
pretty much up you can do an arbitrarily
complicated graph no problem at all
yes so so if you guys do want to look at
the different marks that we the markers
are the types of plots that we support
the B Q plot examples are a great place
to go
we have bars candles graphs now create
heat maps histograms lines bars at
pretty much everything that you want to
do we also have geo plotting and some of
the best said that I thought so yes so
let's let's try that
yes a few in this case if I look if I
have a data file which contains the
results from the 2008 elections Gandhi
wise I think I import a scale which is a
Geo scale like the Albers USA and I just
pass into a passenger BLT de geo this as
you say generated us County's map for me
you can pass an arbitrary geo JSON file
there and I pass the color to it the
cool thing is you could define a tool to
be key block comes with a tooltip object
so I'm asking it to look at the fields
ID name and color so and you can just I
mean we're calling them something else
so once you do that if you display it
you get a full glory let those 538 maps
and if you hover over any one of them it
displays the data that you that that you
requested for it so all of this is on
the Python side no JavaScript necessary
think we're missing Alaska data yes the
cool thing is actually the tool that
doesn't need to be this tooltip object
it can be anything that's basically an
iPod on widget so actually a figure is
an eye Python widget so why don't we try
that we're just going to make the
tooltip instead of making it a regular
tooltip we can make it a full-scale
oops and then set it
I sure what's going on here
I'll have to look into that yeah
a final thing we have is selections the
DQ plot also incorporates d3 notion of
selection which means that even you
select a point it's going to know that
you selected them you can select a lot
of different points so they're selected
as a trait so that means that you can so
say I have the so CF it can knows which
points are being selected on on that
particular graph you can observe the
selected so when selected has changed
you can print it out so select it is
also trait that you can control so if we
select this or that it knows which ones
are being selected and that's the data
that your function is going to be is
going to be getting yes so how do we use
BQ plot so I work as a as a researcher
so it's I mean having visualizations is
cool but there's no particular reason to
deviate from MATLAB one of the big
reasons we we actually use it is is
because the interactivity lets us kind
of figure out quickly what exactly is
happening with our model so in this case
let's pick the simplest model that
everybody knows linear regression in
that and let's let's let's say that we
observe
whenever the Y is change we're going to
observe this function which is going to
recalibrate calibrate the linear
regression and change the and change the
line so you see as you move it the line
is going to recalibrate and change yes
according to according to the point so
you can actually physically see what
happens if your data had been changed a
little it's kind of like a visual
derivative so every time you change the
every time you change a point basically
recalibrates the regression so you can
see how an outlier might affect it or
you can add points or remove points and
that we work as well
yeah so as I was saying earlier one of
the great things about the key plot is
that it's built along with the it's
built on the iPad which is framework
that means that any library that's built
on the I beverages framework can be
leveraged including the I beverages so
in this case we're going to look at
something simple we're just going to
build an in slider which is an object
that I per widgets provides to control
the order of a polynomial and we're
going to say that anytime the value of
this slider is changed you're going to
call this function params change which
is reef it's the reef it's a polynomial
regression on the points that have been
generated so in this case you have a
first-order polynomial you can increase
the order it's going to be a
second-order polynomial can keep
increasing it and the method is going to
keep fitting and you see gradually you
start over fitting the data so I mean
that's kind of how we use BQ blog we're
a team of researchers that built it so
we really built it with kind of data
science and yeah basically research in
mind and the hope is that it can you can
use it to kind of understand your model
better understand your data better
especially now that data is growing
rather fast and hopefully the
interactivity can help you with that yes
so so one of our favorite examples is in
data visualization is the wealth of
nations it it basically was graph done
by Hans Rosling less than that in a
while ago and he was plotting for each
country on the x-axis their income per
capita and the life expectancy on the Y
and using the bubble the size of the
bubble as a way of determining the
population of the country and BQ plot
that's super simple to do because
everything is in Python so we're just
going to read the original JSON file
we're going to clean it so that it's
there very few points we don't really
want to show that and we're going to
generate and most a lot of countries
have missing days so we're going to
linearly interpolate between between
those days for both the income life and
life expectancy as their for income life
expectancy and population so we we do
that here
so one of the big things that he did was
he said he fixed the scale so the scale
being the vision the the x-axis to
representation he fixed it over the men
in the Mac so you really saw the
behaviors in this case we're just going
to compute the min and the max for the X
the Y and the population we'll define a
function that's going to get us the data
for each year that we want to choose so
the first thing we do is we define a
tooltip we pick the fields so in the
case since we're going to do a
scatterplot we want the name the X and
the y so that's going to be the country
name the income per capita and the life
expectancy we're going to have a label
because the way my postdoc did it I
believe is a Gapminder did it yeah they
put a they put the X and the y they put
a little label for the year in the
bottom so we're going to try to recreate
that after that we're going to we're
going to create we're going to have a
log scale on the x axis since income
income has actually grown exponentially
a linear scale on the Y and ordinal
color scale which means that we're going
to color by category and we can define
the category as the region that they're
in so he colored it by continent I
believe initially and yeah and we're
going to define two axes for axes for
those we're going to get the data for
the initial year and create our scatter
so X would be the income per capita the
Y is the life expectancy the color is
the region the size is just the
population the names of the names of the
country we won't display the names to
not clutter the plot we define X Y color
and size as the different scales that
that we're going to need yea and finally
we're we're just going to we're going to
put a tooltip on the on the hover so
we're going to set this diamine when we
we said the uncovered style which means
at the points that are not hovered over
we're going to make their opacity low to
create focus on what you're hovering
over we're also going to add one cool
thing that I don't think my postdoc or
yeah this one so this was the original
one I don't think you had a hover he had
the little label and deck slider over
here so what we're going to do is we're
going to add that yeah so we're going to
add a line take a dime interval we're
going to create a slider for the year
instead of using a deck slider though
that that's their knife edges if that's
what you want to do and every time a
different point is hovered over the
scatter has an attribute called hover
point so you could just observe that
we're going to set the X the Y and we're
going to set the line to be visible so
now every time the slider is moved we
just set the x one and size of the of
that for all the points do exactly the
data for that year finally we add a
little play button and we use the GS
link function in a pie wedges to link
the slider and the play button and voila
so that's going to give you this little
application if you hover you see the
path of any country and income and life
expectancy space if you move the little
slider you're going to see it you're
going to see it animate and generate the
original in well pretty much the
original visualization that that he had
and at any point you can hover over the
country and see its see its path you can
also play the entire thing and that's
going to create a little animation for
you so that's that's a full-blown web
application that we've just generated in
pure Python code we didn't let write a
single line of JavaScript and we pretty
much have all of the interactivity that
we might need other ways that we use it
we so me personally I used it I've used
it to create a kind of denser board for
for data visualization essentially any
time since BQ plod live updates a chart
you can always have streaming data so
basically any time the stream changes
you can just up or the data changes you
can just update your X and your Y and
that's going to trigger a change on the
on the on the line chart the cool thing
about that is basically that if you have
a training if your training or testing a
normal
work helps a lot because basically the
the plot updates as each epoch ends in
training and you get both your train and
your test errors that are updating as
the neural network is is kind of
changing so that that's and that's one
way we use it to not have to really look
at print statements or things like that
you can also have the print statements
but you can basically yeah here you see
the how the Ox score is changing for
your training test data so yes it's
going to keep streaming as the I mean as
bit as all the data as each epoch loads
this helps a lot because you can do this
with any visualization basically here
we're using cars and we're using the
callback function that Garris provides
to just change we're just doing
everything in this function test
underscore call underscore back and
that's just changing the X and the y of
the line based on what score we're
getting at that point so that's that's
one way in which we use them we use this
quite a bit that more advanced ways
would be to do to do something like if
you had your actual network you could
hover over each one and you could get
either the you could get the gradients
or you could get the weights for each
each of the different layers the cool
thing about that is you can study
whether you know a typically networks
that generalize better are ones who have
more of their weights concentrated
typically at the front of the network
versus the back so so yeah you could
study which weather you know you have
better way to the front and the earlier
nodes are in the later nodes and you can
focus on each one of them this is part
of the new graph mark that Chalkley
built actually a couple of weeks back
and yes since like I mentioned any
figure can be put into a tooltip it's no
problem at all do to do this you
basically hold the coders here you can
change the you can change the epoch and
then see what happened to the weights
you can plot the weights as a function
of the epoch you can view the you can
view the gradients if you want you can
see whether you know you're great
they're dying or weather what exactly is
happening or whether you want aggregated
by node or by layer you can look at that
so yeah there's plenty of things that
you can do with with with all of these
different marks that question is I mean
and all of it is in Python so doesn't
really break your data science workflow
to have to do that
the final cool thing that we have is the
notion of an interaction so we for Becky
blog we've defined a kind of grammar of
interactions that it would be built as
before Vega like someone mentioned that
earlier there's - there's new ways of
interacting with your chart and BQ plot
one is that an interaction layer so
those would be the kind of classic d3
selections that you see when you know
you put a little pain over the thing and
as you move the rectangle you see
different things happening so in this
case you know if you have a line chart
you have a you can have a selected thing
on top of that and if you see here in if
you observe the selected attribute
you're going to see what exactly is
being returned to you at that point and
again all of this is in on the Python
side all you have to do is create from
from the interactions you just need to
create a fast interval selector it's one
of our more novel in novel interactions
basically if you go up and increases if
you go down you can even freeze the size
of freeze the thing as as you move
around it's pretty fast way to interact
with the data you can you can use index
selectors so that's going to create
that's going to be that's going to
return only a single point to you you
can yeah and the cool thing is so if you
look at the selected attribute of the
interval selector that you're defining
it's going to return coordinates to you
in this scale but if you look at it at
the on the element on the plot that
you're generating that's actually going
to return to you the indexes of the data
that you're selecting so you could
imagine that actually you could use this
to index a subset of your data and
perform a computation on it if you had
to so that's that's one of the cool
things we can do with the key plot
there we have many different types of
selections we have brush selections you
can customise them quite fully we have
two dimensional brush selections brush
with dates you can select histograms if
you if you had to you could select the
bins of a histogram and visualize what's
happening there it's going to tell you
exactly what ordinates you're selecting
on you can also have multiple selections
on the same graph if you if you
absolutely had to you were it will let
you know what's what's going on there
chrome command need a Mac yep so there
you go so you can have multiple
selections on single graph and it's
going to let you know which things are
being selected there's also a lasso
selector so if you have to declare
something yeah nope yep you can do
multiple selections with dates last
though selections
we pretty much have everything kind of
built in at this point
we also have some pretty original
visualizations that that we build
specifically for financial use cases in
this case we call it a market map it's
kind of a grid map which is laid out in
a much better way so here you see you
don't really see anything so you can
just change the colors change the text
you can change the title of the map the
cool thing is this style map comes with
some some amount of grouping so the
great thing about grouping is you can
group by continent let's say so if you
had a if you if your if your data has
natural inbuilt groups you can show that
in your tile map you can show the groups
if you would like you can select certain
cells in this case just like the scatter
plot you can also change what what you
see when you're selecting those cells
you can also the cool thing is you can
use it as a kind of a pseudo polar plot
so in this case we're going to color by
the GDP of the country and here you can
see that that's going to generate kind
of a mini chloroplast where the
countries with the highest GDP are the
darker colors and the ones that are that
has the lowest GDP are lighter you can
add a widget as a tuple
so you can have the historical GDP of a
country based on which we run whether
you hover over it or not so here we are
Berlin Dora that's the historical time
series for Andorra then for Bulgaria I
mean it's it's a pretty fast way to
visualize all your data especially if
you have a time series for each of your
different data indexes and it's super
easy to do basically you just look at
which symbol was hovered over and you
change an aspect of the line and you
change the title of the figure that's
that's all we're doing right here we're
declaring a market map we have a tool
tip which is figure and basically we
does the market map as a method call on
hover and for that we call this function
hover Handler in that we just get we
care we get which element is being
hovered over we get the data for that
element and we said that to be the Y of
the line and the name of the country to
be title of the figure so which is that
much you can pretty much have something
quite complicated like this so that's
that I mean those are some of the
benefits that we see in terms of using
DQ plot we also provide a lot of a lot
of different mark interactions if if you
if the ideas for I mean if what you want
is for people to interact with it your
your with your plots directly so you can
select on a scatter chart but and that
or you can set the selected on the pipe
inside say when you know another block
was changed you can have tooltips you
can do pretty any widget can be booted
so if you can have a drop down as a
tooltip I don't know why you'd want to
do this clearly just a proof of concept
but you can have pretty much anything
you would want as a tooltip you can put
a figure as a tooltip you can do
whatever you would like basically it's
no problem at all
so in this case when we hover over a
point when we hover over certain points
this one yeah that's going to generate a
line chart pretty much all of the plots
are come with the same grammar
here we we can have a line chart that we
can look at what we can do a certain
thing when at the legend is clicked or
when an element is clicked so here it's
going to tell you this element was
clicked but if we click the legend it's
going to let you know that the legend
was quick basically it's it's aware of
what's happening and it lets you know on
the pipe inside so that you can declare
a function that you know then does
something according to that we have the
same same things in the bar charts you
can select different bars you can have
two tips for those bars you can have
separate behaviors for hover and for
click we have a whole grammar for this
interaction specified you can do the
same thing on four histograms you can
look at the counts and the midpoints you
can make it you can make the tooltip on
a click if you want to freeze the
tooltip you can even do it on a legend
quick if you would like that's that's no
problem at all
you can we have pie charts with
selections and clicking let's say our
interactions are pretty pretty robust
and yeah we built we build them out
pretty well so we're we're pretty we're
pretty happy at them at this point what
we're looking for is we also have built
out a set of applications in this case
we call it we call it that da we call it
DNA is all in the BT blog repos this is
a way to filter out your outliers so
here we're coloring the the data which
has for this outliers it's a canvas
based heat map that we have so you can
increase the range in which you filter
out so you see that in this case all of
these points are the negative outliers
if you wanted to move this slider on the
left this is a in range slider flow
green slider from I bet widget so you
can increase the amount that you let out
and that case you can visualize all of
your outliers and try to see if there's
any sort of pattern that's emerging
whether you know they're on a particular
day or and they're on at a particular
time there's a
I mean there's a there's really pretty
much anything you can you can do with
these you can also set it by tonically
if you want and if you once you've
cleaned the data visually you can get
your you can get this clean data frame
in Python so that's a filtered data
frame that you can then use to do your
data analysis so it's kind of a visual
way the cool thing about that is this is
an this is an object so we define it as
an object so all we have to do is pass
our data frame to it as so and once we
get this clean data frame we can we can
then pass that to another object which
is in turn going to generate another one
so we can do multiple filtering is
depending on which direction we have so
that's another way we use BQ plot we try
to define objects that perform some sort
of computation on the on the different
data we have and then become reusable
because each instance produces a
separate visualization that can then
manipulate your data yeah that's kind of
a that's that's the start of my talk I
wanted to leave some time for questions
if anyone has any
hopefully write your claim post where is
my microphone go
[Applause]